it is a portrait of despair that shook
the world Oscar Ramirez and his 23 month
old daughter valaria died clinging on to
each other an image that his mother at
home in El Salvador cannot shake it was
something that completely destroyed me
it hurts my soul what I'm going through
isn't easy it isn't easy
I wouldn't wish this on anyone she's had
to contend with others describing her
family's tragedy fast words that can
fade how would you like them both to be
remembered I always remember him as a
good father
a good son he was responsible in all
senses of the word my little grandchild
I always remember her as a happy
intelligent girl this house will never
be the same okay they've left an
emptiness that nobody can feel Rosa said
she begged her son not to leave San
Martin a neighborhood filled with
families but controlled by gangs was it
danger he was escaping here or did he
simply want a better life he told he
will be different in the u.s. he wanted
to excel to buy a house that was his
dream
to buy a house for his wife and his
little girl he risked it all and his
sister Wendy has lost her confidence
excellente as a brother he was excellent
we got on really well yes of course we'd
fight about things as brothers and
sisters do but we weren't envious of
each other never we would share
everything with each other even secrets
their desperate journey from this
community has exposed the increasingly
perilous routes that people are taking
to get to the United States el
salvador's president says someday they
will build a country where these things
don't happen but that relief seems a
long way off in death Oscar and valaria
captured a crisis but will they be
enough to spark a solution
cordelia Lynch Sky News San Salvador